- Hi, I'm Anthony Jeselnik,
a famous handsome comedian.
- But this is a podcast, so being handsome
really doesn't help you out that much.
- This is Gregg Rosenthal,
analyst for the NFL network,
for now.
- I do wanna keep my job with the NFL.
- Impossible, you're gonna get divorced,
you're gonna lose your job
and I'll probably end up
with your children.
- That wouldn't be that bad
of an outcome, for them.
- We talk about sports, off
the field issues, comedy.
- People are gonna be
excited, everywhere I go,
people just go up RJVP.
- Yeah, RJVP is dead, now it's the JRVP,
the Jeselnik and Rosenthal Vanity Project.
- You can download it,
subscribe, you can do
whatever you want.
We can't really believe that
this is happening again,
three years after the NFL
took us off their airwave.
- I can't believe you keep
talking about the old podcast.
- I think you gotta give a little shoutout
to the old listeners, just to
say that it existed before.
- People move on with their lives.
- Subscribe please, it'll
be better than last time.
- Mm, half of it's gonna be great.